good evening my name is Rachel Moore and
I am a senior political economy major
here at Hillsdale College tonight I have
the great pleasure of introducing to you
dr. Larry P Arnn dr. Arnn is the 12th
president of Hillsdale College where he
is also a professor of politics and
history he received his bachelor's
degree from Arkansas State University
and his master's and PhD in government
from the Claremont Graduate School he
also studied at Worcester College Oxford
University where he served as director
of research for Sir Martin Gilbert the
official biographer of Winston Churchill
from 1985 to 2000 he served as president
of the Claremont Institute for the Study
of statesmanship and political
philosophy he serves on several boards
of directors and he previously served on
the US Army War College Board of
Visitors for two years for which he
earned the Department of the Army's
outstanding civilian service medal in
2015 he received the Bradley prize from
the land and Harry Bradley Foundation he
is the author of three books Liberty and
learning the evolution of American
education
the founders key the divine and natural
connection between the Declaration and
the Constitution and what we risk by
losing it and most recently Churchill's
trial Winston Churchill and the
salvation of free government please join
me in welcoming dr. Larry Arne
thank you Rachel who's a marvel isn't
she yeah they tend to be um okay I'm
gonna talk the right amount of time now
I have a reminder so I'm sorry I'm not
it well I'm not sorry I'm not at Rollins
but I'm sorry he's not here we still
don't know what happened to him
but we know he was hospitalized and we
think he's okay but we don't have
definite information about that so
remember him in your prayers I know him
a little I've met him several times but
one time and lord I came everyone it
wasn't so long ago I was in meetings
with him for a few hours about a failed
political campaign for a synonym for the
US Senate and not mine in California you
missed a treat because you know he was
Reagan's gonna break ins key political
guides and so I'd always imagined
somebody like Reagan I guess what he is
is he's quick as a cat and he's a wild
storyteller mostly not off-color and
peninnah so you're missing a treat not
having him but I'll do my best
I'm proud to be here I'm proud to talk
to the students at the college all the
time they're my favorite thing my
colleagues faculty and staff or a lot of
them here thank you for coming and thank
you visitors you're always welcome here
somebody said to me today yeah well you
operate at a very elevated level here at
Hillsdale College and that's true but I
also want you to know that when they get
here when they're 18 years old they're
very young and so don't ever feel that
you're not able to learn just like they
are you have the advantage of age on
them at least so I have four points I
think the Republican Party today faces
of the crisis and it's like the cry
is that it was born to face I will say I
don't save so far it does so well as the
original one but the original one didn't
at the beginning either I'm gonna say a
little bit about what that crisis was
then and what's like it today I guess
those are my first and second points I'm
gonna say what I think the Republican
Party is trying to do about it today and
what I think it should do those are
different things the last but there you
go if you notice that politics are
always in a crisis it's the nature of
the beast right in Hillsdale Michigan we
have crises all the time you know shall
we increase the income tax shall we
discipline the cable provider you know
it's always a crisis but sometimes there
are real ones
and now how would you know when they're
real ones I think they're real ones when
they affect the fundamental things that
make the country what it is and I think
those are knowable I think they're noble
about anything by the way about any
human thing for sure things have their
definition from the purposes they serve
and they have their definition from the
way they go about serving them in
classical thought that would be the
final and the formal cause and it's not
hard in America to say what those two
causes are the final cause is stated in
the Declaration of Independence in the
laws of nature and nature's God and
things that you know about human beings
because of them well you know about
human beings that they are equal equal
in their humanity equal in their right
to consent to the government over them
the same kind of thing is what it means
and in America we have on three
occasions had big disputes about those
two things one of them was in the
Revolution when I was in the Civil War
and I think one of them is today you
heard Charles today an old friend of
mine Charles Kesler who's very wise man
and so you have some preparation for
understanding what the Republican Party
had to face at the beginning it was a
crisis about
final cause of the land in the founding
among the leading founders it is simply
never to be found that they thought that
human slavery was right under the terms
of the Declaration of Independence they
agonized about it
also they reduced its goal by about
sixty percent in the generation that
followed the Declaration of Independence
and they thought that was right in 1797
we laid down the way that the country
would grow in the Northwest Ordinance
and it would grow by not by colonies
first time this had ever happened but by
the admission of equal states full of
equal citizens and in that ordinance
there aren't many very many things that
happened in that ordinance and turned
out if you look at any old law in
American history you will find that it
is brief which is unknown today but one
of the things that sets up the system of
Education which makes us talk unto
itself and it's a very different purpose
than we serve today with education in
most places but they provide that
there's to be no slavery in this new
first territory which includes Michigan
and Ohio and three other states there's
to be no slavery in those places ever
and that was on the motion of Thomas
Jefferson a slave holder and the land
was ceded to the Union by Virginia a
slave state and that happened relatively
without controversy and then exactly 33
years one generation later the Missouri
Compromise was passed and that was to
admit Missouri but now it was very
controversial whether the number of
slave and the number of free states
would be equal in the United States
Senate and that means that there was a
force that has arisen of great political
force that slavery is a good thing and
it should be extended those are two
grand documents in the history of
America and they say opposite things
about that question they both would
speak of the time and what people
thought at that time and for some reason
people had begun to Sun sank many people
not all turned out not a majority but
that was hard to say at any given point
thought that slavery was good that's
articulated best in the writings of John
Calhoun who you can read in our
Constitution reader as well for that
matter as the Northwest Ordinance and
what he said was they're different and
not equal because of race in other words
the essential thing about them is not
that they can talk and they walk upright
and they have a conscience
the essential thing about them is their
color which is a token of their race and
their race of course that's a historical
subject race unfolds over time it's
passed down from generation to
generation and he said that these had
through a process of history he did not
so far as I can remember use the
expression evolution but others did
Alexander Stephens the vice president of
the Confederacy did they had evolved to
a lower place and it would be an
abomination it would be a betrayal of
the race it would be a betrayal of the
upward direction of human nature history
if we did if we had blacks and whites
living together is equal in their
political rights they're not the same
kind of thing was his argument and and
you know John Calhoun study did Yale and
he studied with the student of Friedrich
Hegel one of the prime authors of the
historicism that afflicts America today
and this change is debate now argument
which led to the most costly war in
American history that also immediately
did what such causes always do when they
operate and that is they started putting
pressure on the form of the government
and there were enormous changes
recommended and
that would be the the the pace of the
crisis was much governed by the presence
of the Western plans one of the greatest
movements in human history is the
movement of the American people across
the United States it's hardly anything
to think of like that and I wrote a
motorcycle with somebody's mind and my
son across the country he learned it
really is a wagon big old country and
when they start out set out to settle it
and make it the Empire of Liberty as
George Washington liked to say they
didn't really know how big it was and
and while they were doing that because
1820 his Wayne is is a because that's
when the Missouri Compromise was that's
when the pressure arose because now we
got to decide are we going to have
slavery in those places or not and those
places until they're formed as states
are governed directly by the federal
government and so slavery requires a big
system of laws go in the Constitution
reader of Hillsdale College and I'll add
a point when I mentioned that you know
Hill so cut is a very different place
than most academic institutions for
reasons I'm going to state in a minute
but I want you to know that it is an
academic place then that means that we
study things and learn things by arguing
about them and we try to read everything
relevant so our Constitution reader like
our history readers both of them like
the things we read in literature often
disagree with each other indeed in the
Constitution reader most of the readings
are written by people who don't much
like the Constitution the United States
which is sort of how the political
controversies in the in the nation's
history have gone especially in recent
decades so you can read the Alabama
slave code in there it's in there and
you know it's not limited government
because there's detailed regulations
about where and for how long and under
what circumstances black people can a
symbol or leave the plantation but there
are also lots of regulations about
whites about who you can have in your
house free white males were required to
run to ride Posse once a month looking
for
runaways whether they were slaveholders
or not and you know the inconvenient
thing about slavery especially if you
think it's a really good thing and good
for the slaves is they had this terrible
habit of trying to get away you didn't
see so commonly the master is running to
get away from the slaves it was the
slaves trying to get away so are you
gonna have laws that protect it and if
you are then you're gonna have a
different kind of federal law that's
gonna prepare the way for a union
because more states would come in with
slavery in them and that would
constitute what Lincoln called a
peculiar interest and so that's a fight
about the form of the government not
just whether it will protect slavery but
also how intrusive it will be on people
and so those two things confronted the
Republican Party in the beginning and
just like the founding of the country
and the success of the revolution and
the extension of the country across the
land you wouldn't bet on their success
when you looked at them starting looked
hopeless and it nearly was and it turned
out different well I think this problem
today is like that problem in those two
respects it's a reason I think it's a
crisis that word crisis means turning
point remember Lincoln said famously a
house divided against itself cannot
stand well this is a divided house now
we've got more than one way of thinking
about government and more than one way
very heavily entrenched in government
and that starts with some claims about
the final cause of the government and I
think that those claims that they're
made today in the American Academy above
all from witnesses problem stems and
where it gets its chief energy today are
like the claims that were made in the
Confederacy except they're not
understanding themselves to be on the
right trying to preserve an old order
one of the things that happened in the
Confederacy's they rewrote history an
awful lot we all do that according to
the political
passions of the day we try not to do
that at Hillsdale College that's why
it's hard to be an academic but they did
that quite a bit and they said they told
a news story about Americans story was
the declaration independence was never
meant to be very important and this
principle of equality is not what the
country was all about he was all about
something else it was about us ruling
our local societies however we might
please and so today what is the story
the story today is not on the right
trying to preserve an old order but it's
kind of like it in other respects
because what it does is it substitutes
for this idea of nature the idea of
history or change like that idea in John
Calvin's
account of the inferiority of the blacks
what does it mean first of all what is
nature mean nature comes from a land
where the means to grow and you know you
planted you plant an acorn and unless
you intervene with modern science which
you can do you're going to get an oak
tree out of that thing what is trying to
do is become an oak tree and that once
you see that that starts with that Latin
word for birth and it means the
beginning and growth that produces a
living thing then it also comes to mean
what the thing is when it's fully grown
its essence its meaning the oak tree is
superior to the Acorn because it's what
the Acorn is trying to produce and it
can't mean what it's like when it de
current decays living things all decay
and so it's not just old it's not just
age in fact at the end of the age
they're less like themselves in fact at
the end living things turn into dust all
of them do it's like what it's like when
it reaches its excellence so the nature
is the essence of a thing and so when we
say we have our rights in nature it
means we have them from what we are look
at us you can see how do we act what do
we like we're human right in some ways
that's a kind of pitiful thing to be
compared it to a mansion to do what you
imagine an angel to be but if you're
like me and my wife you take enormous
pleasure from the cavorting of dogs and
we
the worst dogs in Hillsdale County and
the thing is that just always act like
dogs it's just the coolest thing you
ever saw
but they're dogs you know and one time I
said depending cuz they stare at you you
know and they and penny thinks they're
trying to put telepathic signals into
her mind and I said I think that he's
quivering on the threshold of
understanding and penny said penny
replied Betty doesn't cross it history
is something different what if you think
a plausible thing to think and this is
the argument that all of us would think
radically differently in this room if we
had grown up in Rome or in Sparta versus
Athens to things that lived at the same
time culture matters so much doesn't it
that word culture is also cognate with
the word means to grow so maybe we're
not really just a nature blessed with
understanding and capable of reading the
book and see what it means no matter
when that book was written maybe where
we are as a product of our experiences
and it does seem that experiences are
very powerful learn thing and
historicism what we think is they're all
powerful we even think writes John Dewey
and remember all of this is related to
the thought for example of Karl Marx who
was a kind of a popularizer of angle and
he turned it into a political agenda you
can estimate what's going on in the
economy and you can see how the
revolutions going to go well if we're
all products of our history that's kind
of despairing isn't it because it means
that this argument that I'm making and
whatever you make of this argument this
argument is just produced by the
circumstances my circumstances and the
circumstances of the people who taught
me we don't have any independence from
the facts we confront in life Frank good
now one of the main progressive thinkers
in American history is in our
Constitution reader of course and he
says in there we teachers take ourselves
too seriously because our students are
ultimately just going to think whatever
the economic
editions of the day tell them to think
that's kind of sad I didn't it that
might be part of the reason why in the
school today what we tell kids today is
that the truth is what you think it is
and your job is to just figure out
whatever you think it is
we don't cozy him along quite like that
here at Hillsdale College they do say
you know natively because they grow up
in this world they'll say if you ask him
a hard question they'll often say
according to whom they don't say that
worst thing yet you just want my opinion
about that they know better than that
but they'll say whose answer do you want
and we try to you know I'm the fund of
Aristotle so there we Shia they they
look up Aristotle's answer and try to
tell me what that is and I always say
well I'm not asking about that nor did
air so I'm wondering what the dang thing
is what is that thing if you have a
human nature and if the classical and
faithful religious account a Christian
account of it is true you can do that
but if the history account is true you
can't and that takes the wind out of a
lot of sales and also destroys the
principle of human freedom so what can
relieve that terrible despair well
there's an opportunity latent in that if
you want you accept it it turns out that
science that that's an old Latin word
that means to know the Natural Science
meant knowing about natural things
things that just grow of their own or
are of their own not by human making now
that word science comes to mean a kind
of making you can study a thing and take
it apart and you can figure out how to
change it and in that case then maybe
you could remake the whole society
because if people are produced by these
circumstances that unfold then you could
produce the people however you please am
i reading for to tallit area looks in a
class with my students this term and
they're just delightful intercourse
frightening 1984 and doctor
and three other things like that but
what are they saying these torturers and
imprisoners and leaders of the
revolution they say we can make you into
whatever we want you to be when they
mean it kindly they mean we can perfect
the society in 1984 they don't mean the
client kindly O'Brien says to Winston
Smith I can only be sure that you're
obeying me when you were in pain the
rest of the time you might just be doing
what you want we can't have that doesn't
necessarily have to be kindly because by
the way what would be the dignity of
kindness is against unkindness according
to these principles well the American
progressives were Americans and they had
a bright outlook on the world they
thought we can really just fix
everything if we just apply scientific
administration to the government and
this constitution is kind of in the way
you know and because it's all these
checks and balances that just messes up
everything right because we've got to
get ourselves an administration that's a
big word in the in the Constitution
reader you'll see in the progressive
section the word administration is often
italicized in their writings like do you
love administration you know I managed
the college administration I guess but
we don't talk about that much here
because I personally hate the term and
think that's not reven what I do right
I've got to take care of the business of
the college but the college is a
teaching place and that's what it's
supposed to be about so admit but
administration is a name to conjure with
with these people and they even like the
term bureaucracy and so the cut not only
does the Constitution have to change
that has to change because the final
cause has changed right if it's true the
change is the only real fact in nature
then the only freedom we could have
would be to gain control of the process
of change and so one of the features of
that and this is visible I mean if you
go to the National Mall
what's it like if you're been there it's
just the greatest place right and it was
laid out by the founders themselves
three of them and an architect a French
architect and in the hub the hub of the
shape that they design is the capital
the heart of the nation's common
political activity and the states the
big avenues are named for States and
they come out like spokes so it's a
wagon big old wheel and it won't work
unless the hub and the spokes are
connected and in their rightful place
and then it's also pure it's built like
Roman architecture or Greek architecture
and on purpose deliberately and if you
just look at the architecture of the
individual buildings first of all they
are beautiful which is a difference from
modern bureaucratic buildings which are
just pug ugly and I even think that's
natural that they would be given what
they're for but if you just look at the
Capitol in the White House
they're both dominated by public spaces
both of them have big entrances welcome
you know be quite steps going up to the
Capitol very wide lots of doors to get
in and when you go in the main door
you're under a massive rotunda and it
invites you to look up and also to mill
around and lots of people can be in
there it's a public space up at the tops
of all these statues of the people who
made America down through time but up at
the top there's a fresco on the top it's
very beautiful I've been up there and
it's a George Washington is sitting up
there very high and other founders
around him and various symbols of the
causes of freedom that's how that's
designed and you know the the whole
presidential staff worked in the White
House through the Civil War and beyond
actually grants administration I think
is really bill T what we now call the
old executive office building the
architect said to President Grant at the
dedication and you know it's fireproof
mr. president and Ulysses Grant said
pity
but you know Abraham Lincoln ran his the
presidential office with most of the war
two employees later three and there were
four cabinet offices at the beginning
and there wasn't anything on the
National Mall except those things and it
had a poised above it the Supreme Court
was originally in the capital and they
all look like places that that kind of
government which is emphatically not
administrative in its character would go
on and of course now it's transformed
and much of it is ugly there's a place
you can stand say 300 yards from the
Capitol facing the Capitol on the
National Mall and you get a really great
view of the Capitol east wing of it I
think it is and then if you look sharp
Lee to the right there is the United
States Department of Education in all
its glory right and if you just look
back and forth that the to which I do
from time to time first time I did it I
nearly fell over when I saw what it
meant right because what it looks like
the Department of Education is like a
Bureau like you know one of those dances
that you can put your papers up in and
and that's that function you couldn't
put that function in the Capitol or any
of the buildings that are original for
the government the interstates and when
I say original I mean for a hundred
years and we say now that that had to be
built because the society is so complex
well it is terribly complex isn't it but
wasn't it complex back then because
think what they did they built the first
free government in history from roots in
colonial experience mainly in some
English experience right but a different
thing in kind too and then they defeated
the largest nation in history and then
they settled the continent of the United
States the population and gross domestic
product of the country growing faster
than anything China has achieved in
modern times right and they didn't even
when they set out on the journey across
they didn't know who
where they were going right they never
you know Lewis and Clark is eighteen six
or seven or eight somewhere in there
well George Washington was calling his
army the Continental Army Army in 1779
he didn't how big the continent was
right and they did all of that and they
did it under the same form and the
country became huge and the greatest
power on earth and they solved the
problem in those ways and now we have
different ways and those ways are
centralized in their nature
I was Kim what meeting I can't tell my
gonna tell you what meeting I was in
today but I was in a college presidents
meeting today I don't go to many of them
I'm very pleased to report to you but
this particular bunch I like and we were
dealing with some commands from a
regulatory body about how to run our
colleges in certain respects right and
the people who sent those first of all
they can't write to save their lives but
I think they don't want to I think they
can write the way they want to write
hard to read technical convoluted need
an expert to read it and they're telling
us to do things and everybody sitting in
the room is right now running a college
with some success and we're all just
shaking our hands now most bodies of
college presidents would not be done
that this is a special breed but I I
said at one point you know shall we sign
this thing all right you know it's up to
each one of us to sign it or not sign it
it's a pledge to do a certain thing
that's very politically correct and it's
a personal pledge we're supposed to sign
and I said well I'm not gonna sign it
and they said dad why not and I said
well I haven't thought about it very
much but it just isn't the kind of thing
I was signed unless I made two and they
said why and I said it's the wrong kind
of thing what is that to them what does
they know about it if it is asking me to
try to be fair well lord help us if I
couldn't pass that standard you
to try to be fair that'd be pitiful what
they really asked me to do is try to be
fair in the ways that they say now and
then under this vague document will say
tomorrow and the next day and the day
after that and the day after that right
that's the way every week now at
Hillsdale College there's some new
things you know there's a federal
minimum wage for salaried employees do
you know that I found it out in a board
report before our board meeting two
weeks ago I was reading and you know I
hate those things
I love the colleagues who write them for
me but they're two of them who write me
about stuff like this frequently and I
said to thee to one into the newer one
not long ago in a staff meeting I said
you must get to the older one I said you
must be very glad that the newer ones
here and they both laughed out loud in
there and the newer one said yeah a
different messenger to shoot it's crazy
right and it's constant all the time I
got a thing on a former Athletic
Conference we were in one time we were
we were berated to go and check right
now and do not let the morning pass
without checking about the 25 percent of
our young women who were being raped or
assaulted and so the meeting ended is 15
to 12 and so I thought I'll be that I
said I'll call Diane Phillip the vice
president for student affairs and I'll
say Diane I need information please
about the 25 percent of our young women
who are being assaulted and raped and
she said well dr. on the number is lower
than that I said good I said what would
it be and she said well you know the
number I said we've had one allegation
of rape in my 17 years in here and then
she's told me something I didn't know at
the time this is a couple of years ago
she said we haven't caught a young man
in the wrong room in the wrong dormitory
in the morning for five years reduces
the opportunity for that kind of thing
but anyway are they gonna do that and I
said okay but the claim is that it's
going on all the time
we don't know it and she's a real smart
woman I said what about that she said
well of course we didn't know and we
wouldn't know it but I said what do you
think she said well we have an RA living
on every wing and every floor of every
dormitory and we meet with them every
week and we have a culture here if the
students do something wrong we're not
trying to hurt them and we know that and
you know they're young and stupid of
course they do things that are wrong but
mostly it's amusing when they do and if
they're quick to apologize we're very
quick to forgive and that means we don't
want them afraid to tell us things
because apart from bad behavior which is
not very common around here they got all
kinds of problems they're trying to grow
up in the modern world and they're
trying to deal with this faculty and
that is the devil of a problem so you
see it's just you know and you know I
can tell you if somebody assaults
somebody around here if somebody slurs
somebody around here we don't like that
and it doesn't happen very much and one
of the reasons it doesn't is everybody's
committed not to do that before they
come here because you can't live like
that if you're going to learn together
what about that spirit that spirit is
unknown to these regulations because the
regulations are written about something
that can be controlled from a central
source and of course everything is
cookie cutting cutter and everything is
compliance and the crisis of the formal
cause the constitutional crisis is
simple our government is representative
form the first purely representative
form and to control for private people
of society to control something as
powerful as the government and make no
mistake our government was built to be
and needs to be very powerful wasn't
easy to beat the king of England won't
be easy to fight the wars that are going
on or looming for us right now
not easy to
check the persons and property of a
great nation need strength so how are
you going to delegate that strength and
yet keep it from getting out of hand and
the Constitution United States is the
greatest answer to that question that's
ever been devised and so the point is if
it breaks down if the government gets
larger than the people and in economic
terms it is larger than the society the
private society right now as we speak if
you count the regulatory cost and here's
another thing what they're doing in all
those new ugly buildings in Washington
DC is they're making laws and in
addition they're enforcing those laws in
the same agency and when cases arise
under those laws they're adjudicating
those laws and so inside each agency
there is no separation of powers and
that means when you hear from one of
them you should be afraid somebody
working there has already made a
decision about you and who do you appeal
to the poor Congress you know how many
people hate Congress you know if there's
350 million people 3 and 50 1 million of
them hate Congress and they're in a
pitiful shape and the Republican Party
to speak of the Republican party today
is controlling Congress right now and
what would they have to do to get their
grips on this thing there are two tools
available to them since this was set up
in a grievous and terrible mistake over
60 years in the past because remember
what's happened here is the Congress and
president have delegated their authority
to these independent agencies who are
tenured the staff members and who are
mostly governed by boards that rotate
all the time and they're sealed off from
politics and to seal them off from
politics just to seal them off from us
and so the only way you can fix it is if
you can pass a law through both houses
of car
and get the president to sign it that's
the first way and of course for the
first time in American history in the
last two generations government is
typically divided and so when one of
those things gets in it's very hard to
get it out that by that means the second
means is the budget because it was true
for example in the breagan
administration which Charles was talking
about today it was true that the
Congress was very tough and so I had
friends who worked in the Reagan
administration and they would have to go
testify on Congress and they feared that
experience and if Congress didn't like
what they did they would pass an
appropriation bill that deleted their
salary from the agency and they fire
them well we're not doing that anymore
right
we're not passing budgets and
appropriation bills anymore now we do
continuing resolutions and we can't
reach agreement about those things now
one of the things the Republican Party
is doing today is they're trying to be a
lot more serious about passing
appropriations bills and they still
haven't got it done and there's a lot of
reasons why they don't want to miss just
the pressure of the vast expenditure and
the interest get around it are huge but
a second one is if you pass an
appropriations bill it's a big
compromise bill there's gonna be a whole
bunch of ugly stuff in it and the
individual members their congressional
rating by if they're liberal by the
liberals and if they're conservative by
the concerns will get hurt and so
they're they're weak now and then add to
that everybody like me I I bet it's true
that the Faculty of Hillsdale College
knows everybody in the country who's an
academic who would more or less agree
with what I'm saying tonight and so that
means that the overwhelming majority of
authoritative opinion is against them
and they're outnumbered and the current
president is extremely good at these
politics and and look what he's done I
mean there's a federal he didn't do it
but there is a federal minimum way
now for salaried employees the same for
every city in the land I'm told that
means Hillsdale College and Manhattan
same salary minimum required so there's
that but you know think of this
immigration thing because it was just
announced that under the prosecutorial
power prosecutorial discussion doesn't
discretion the president would not
prosecute anybody here in the country
illegally and that's millions of people
but that means by the way that the
executive branch by itself is making a
determination that will affect
ultimately who are the citizens and in
the old days it was thought the citizens
should pick the government but now it
seems to work the other way around
there's no private institution in
America including this one that is not
threatened by this one way or another
but apart from the threats and the
dangers in the moat you can build just
it's just true that the massive energy
that is released by letting people
govern themselves is the strongest force
in human history because God made us
that way right you want to know why the
college works the way it does it works
it's good College one of the reasons is
everybody here wants to do it all these
little kids you know who show up here
and leave adults or as I like to say
almost human beings
they make a commitment about that before
they come and they're warned right and
so what we do is we end up with a bunch
of people who are foolish right they
want to you know you tell us a whole you
tell you know our population is 18 year
old kids who could go to college just
about wherever they want and you tell
them if you come here you're really
gonna have to suffer and they go yeah
let's do that
I'm on that right you know it's foolish
but it's great one reason they're not
very good is that they're overwhelmed
another reason they're not very good is
that they don't know the things that
people used to know
leaders at least used to know I just put
an argument together how we're good a
student I am I will tell you I've been
working on these things for a long time
with really great teachers and I can't
put that argument together and what if
you can't then when you go there it just
looks like things are like this and
they've always been like this I mean
Lord they're physically entrenched now
22 million people work for the
government state local and federal great
majority local and federal but they work
under general federal directives for the
most part they don't know hard to make
the distinction I mean if you go read
Abraham Lincoln what you'll find out is
he put together and could repeat from
memory a complete history of the
movements of slavery in the nation also
what the leading people said about it
also the arguments at the heart of it
that have to do with the essence of the
human being in other words when he
walked out on the stage and the
lincoln-douglas debates he had command
sublime profound awesome to see not many
like that ever in history and very few
today and when fundamental things are
pin tending it's better to know and so
part of it is just build ermand they're
just bewildered the early Republican
Party Lincoln says about if I can find
it
I can't find it it doesn't matter so
I'll close by saying what I think we
should do what I hope they will do they
are trying harder many of them in the
Congress and they're frightened a lot of
my friend now it's frightening to me
when I see that they didn't used to be
so frightened used to be I could
frighten them now they're already
frightened now I try to buck him up when
I talk to him they should become
articulate about the meaning of the
nation this idea of equality that we can
engineer people to come out the same
that takes the Gestapo you're just not
gonna be able to do that you've been to
any classes here at Hillsdale College
everybody's smart they don't all make
the same grades
it's just they can do different things
right and some of them can do awesome
well all of them can do them well but
you can't make them the same it won't
work
they're not made that way you can force
them to seem more the same and so we
should repudiate that understanding of
equality we should think that equality
is a natural fact not a thing to be
engineered the second thing is we should
defend the form of the government we
should become articulate about that we
should think that the country is
supposed to be governed under a set of
rules that limit the government and us a
third thing we should do is we should
emphasize citizenship that's happening
right now in politics on a big scale in
other words the big fact that is
relevant to whether you get to
participate in the governing of America
is whether or not you are a citizen it's
so bad now by the way and we move so
fast toward international government I
have you noticed by the way that these
principles that I named of progress ISM
they're not specifically American in any
way our declaration of dependence is
universal but it establishes the
universal right to consent of the
governed you make it your own by giving
it your can
and there isn't any principle in these
progressivism ideas to make it your own
it's everybody's right and since its
it's an expertise that gives title to
managing the society toward the future
really experts or sovereign that's why
to mention that somebody's not a citizen
is to be accused of racism somebody said
something about a judge being a Mexican
and everybody took that as a racial
comment well maybe it was meant that way
I don't know but it is just a fact that
Mexico is not race it took me a little
while to think of that but I once I did
oh yeah that's right you know it we
should we should emphasize the fact that
this country is for hours and a great
phrase to use is from Winston Churchill
he sit one time in the House of Commons
in exasperation and you know he was so
eloquent so you could you could not do
worse than comprehend he said to a
Labour member he said do you not
understand that there is no question
raised in this house that can be rightly
or effectively resolved by expertise the
questions of justice and freedom are the
human property all of us are entitled to
them nobody knows more about them in
principle than anybody else
and if you do more it's only because
you've read and studied and thought more
than the next person and what you've
read and studied and thought about is
not technical in its nature and that
means finally that we should repudiate
this kind of government the kind of the
thing is what's wrong with it we
shouldn't we shouldn't adjust it we
shouldn't make it more accountable it's
just a fact that nobody since Ronald
Reagan none of his successors have made
that the center of their lives as he did
beginning with the time for choosing
speech in 1964 and that leads me to my
conclusion which is just too hopeful
things when I'm is if the problem is we
haven't tried sufficiently maybe we
could try
maybe this emergency will produce the
effort and the second one is this
college is thriving even if threatened
and it's ready to fight it will go on
thank you
we now have time for a few questions
please when the microphone is brought to
you she said if you have a question hold
your hand doctor are you speak a lot
about what the good is in your opinion
what is the good in relation how a
nation should be lighted okay that's
good I torture them with the question of
good rare chance for you to ask me back
they always try to ask me what do you
think it is now I said I don't care what
I think it is what is it so the good of
a thing according to Aristotle is the
being of a thing what the thing is right
so if a thing is destroyed you know if
the bottle cut the bottom out of it it's
not a bottle anymore maybe it'll make a
funnel so what is the good of the nation
that's not hard to say right because it
it did start it has a birthday and the
birthday says we hold these truths to be
self image that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights that to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men then it goes on
later to say we always forget this they
say life liberty and pursuit of
happiness in the Declaration of
Independence and facili people including
very erudite scholars have said that by
using pursuit of happiness and not
happiness they were saying each person
is allowed to devise his own happiness
and of course to some extent that's true
but in the extent that you're gonna act
like a horse or you're gonna be a drug
addict or you're gonna what you know the
point is that it's not gonna make you
happy because that's not what it is to
be good two sentences later it says that
they can throw off the government and
establish a new government according
such forms as to them shall be most
likely to achieve their to affect their
safety and happiness unqualified right
that's two sentences later and the
purposes of the American government
our consent of the governed contributing
to safety and Happiness and our freedom
is written in the same place so I think
but I don't think that I just happened
to read it there's an argument out there
that the Republican Party would have
never come into existence had not a
conditional suffrage in the 1820s
expanded into universal male suffrage by
the 1850s
and that is it was Universal male white
male suffrage that you know led to the
Civil War dr. Kessler was talking about
the fact that there is one party of
which we have two parties derived from
and over the years we've expanded
suffrage and now we have a culture of
very small groups of people with very
vocal grievances and we've got political
parties catering to those grievances is
it this may seem like a dumb question
but is it possible suffrage we have too
much suffrage and that some form of
conditional suffrage may be the
salvation of the Republic so you're not
confusing suffrage with suffering so
first of all I don't think that's true
about that argument about the 1850s but
never mind that
what the founders thought was that
suffrage had to be wide enough to
represent the great body of the people
there's no reason in principle and there
is reason to think that you might limit
the suffrage to tax payers when sin
Churchill proposed something like that
in England he wanted everybody to have a
vote
people who paid taxes to have to man or
woman he's proposed that in the 30 so
there's good constitutional arguments
about that but that doesn't change two
facts that are in my opinion more
important first of all the first
constitutional check is in America is
that they can't do anything unless the
people say they can right that's the
that's the single most important reason
why governments are kept from getting
out of control after then all the
problems come in about us oppressing the
minority well the second point would
have to be that you would have to have
at least a very large majority of people
voting because other that some minority
could form a closer interest quicker
than a majority could rights Madison and
the 10th Federalist so you're gonna need
very wide suffrage but then I'll add
this final point what I think today is I
say this to friends of mine in
Washington these days my fellow
conservative leaders as I'm styled
sometimes I say first of all do you
think people like us are gonna save the
American people you talk for a living
and have lots of education because we're
the problem I mean it's true we're a
little rump in that bunch but there
ain't many of us so what about the fact
that the common sense opinions of
ordinary people are actually on some
really fundamentals they appear to be
much more sound than elites and I don't
think that the driving problems in
America today are coming from most
people I actually think that they're
coming from highly educated people who
would astray a hundred years ago and
more
dr. R can you love given that the
appropriations process favors control by
leadership and omnibus budgets and
continuing resolutions and so forth can
you describe a scenario where control
the Appropriations could retreat from
the continuing resolutions and nomina
bust budgets to departmental
appropriations like you described
earlier I'm gonna try to that's
representative Lloyd Houser who actually
is the first car dealer to get a
promotion no to get a demotion by going
into politics so your question is is it
a question about how much control the
leadership should have in a legislative
body Oh how do we do it yeah well I'm a
more disciplined in the caucus fella I
think the speaker should be strong and I
think that I you have to remember that
there's almost nothing that that you can
name that would really work today
because a complex of things is wrong so
one of the things that wrong is that the
there are actually a much higher
percentage of safe seats in the house
than there are in the Senate and it
makes the Senate at a very cowardly body
and the house is bolder because not many
seats change hands in the house and
that's because of gerrymandering but
it's also because of the effect of the
administrative state on politics
congressman just get a lot of moxie out
of doing stuff for their constituency
getting stuff out of the bureaucracy
which is kind of one of their prime jobs
now so especially if it were more
competitive than it is then there would
be little harm and having very strong
speakers because the effect of that and
leadership effect of that would be then
they would actually take a position on
the grand things that matter the budget
the big issues of principle the scope of
the government those are the big
questions that are open today right
because you know we're in danger I think
of being overwhelmed by the
and I don't go to any meetings myself in
any kind of meeting development meeting
around here running the college other
college people outside I don't go to
anybody where any meetings where people
are not afraid to cross the government
and it's everywhere now so if there was
a party and and hey I want to say
something about our part in founding the
Republican Party which is very noble you
know the first platform of the
Republican Party was first draft or an
early draft it was written in central
hall by two guys who worked here write
very great people but I also want to
remind everybody that before they did
that they were Whigs
and you know a lot of the early
documents and the story of the college
you can find in a local publication
called the Hillsdale Whig standard right
so in other words we do have a history
of forming parties we also have a
history of leaving them so I you know
I'm a member of the Republican Party but
I wanted to be good according to that
definition right there and if something
comes along that's better it's very hard
to replace a political party I would
like to see it maneuver it into a place
where it's got to take a bunch of really
strong positions and so I agree it
should be stronger leadership probably
if that's what you think yeah
darn we came here to this
democrat-republican seminar my question
has been has been answered and secured
its ways I would like for one of you two
to capsulize in brief the distinction
between Republican political philosophy
and democratic political philosophy our
candidates don't talk about that that's
not on the table
well it's would you could you capitalize
for us I'll take a stab at it is that he
that I'm going to take the property of
the chair and to say I left off one of
my prime things we have to undo the
politically correct controls on language
you know that thing I said about the
Mexican judge
I think one of the reasons people
believe that gasps because he's prepared
to say stuff like that and I don't even
know if he does it artfully or not but
and he causes outrage and sometimes I
really like it so what are the two so
first of all it's a difficult thing to
do because the parties are not coherent
and candid about what they stand for in
ways that they had been in the past when
they were great
so they give confused and and of course
everything they say about themselves is
designed to attract the voters and so
they don't sit down and write down clear
simple treatises what they believe a
good spat that it would be what is the
difference between democracy and
republicanism and that difference too is
not written in nature but by all
practice but deimos the deems are they
means groups of ten right in the ranks
of the Greek city-states the nobles
would be upfront important people and
then the ordinary folk or in ranks of
ten behind an aqua crk means rule or
ruling principle and so the beans rule
that means the meaning rule and
Aristotle for one doesn't think that's a
very good form of government but
republicanism so Madison defines that
strictly in the in the Federalist as all
political power is drawn from the great
body of the people and that means it's
not the same thing that saying everybody
decides everything in other words to
have republicanism at least in the
American sense and Republic by the way
that just comes from words that means
the public things right but so that's a
latin word old word but in America
republicanism means we rule through
forms that are that are design
and to grant the power and control it
and control by the way even our granting
of it so the way Madison uses the term
it's a symbol for constitutionalism
because see if you have a tyranny one
person rules however whatever he wants
right you don't necessarily have to have
a Constitution and if you do it's a
fraud if you're gonna have rule mixed up
among a lot of people you're gonna have
to have some big rules a constitution
about how they do that so I think that
in its route in America as it was used
in early practice and more or less
consistently since the Republicans are
the people who think that the people
should rule but through a constitution
and democracy is a term and was used as
a term of aspersion a lot in the
founding about the idea that just all
the people would vote and me and and and
rule because the argument was and I
agree with the argument that will go
wrong consistently that he'll know right
well I actually spoke tonight about what
I think is the driving idea behind the
democratic party I'll restate it I'm
happy to and I'll try to put you know
the best face on it I can because it is
a kind of a very attractive and magical
idea what if it's true that you could
use the tools of science to eliminate
all the evils in society nobody wants to
die of cancer at all and nobody wants to
die today what if you could make
everybody live a really long time and be
terribly healthy to the end right what
if nobody wants somebody to suffer in
squalor and poverty because their
parents were sick whereas somebody else
is a wastrel all his life and born to
wealth and nobility and never does a bit
of public serious work nobody wants that
that's unjust that's bad right so what
if by scientific
application of management and other
tools you could eliminate all those
terrible things what if you could do
that right and the reason we haven't
been able to do it the reason we can do
it now says the founders of the modern
Democratic Party I think it's a fact
this is true what they said was we have
invented human beings scholars others
have invented whole new ways of
approaching the problem of governance it
should be neutral tenured scientific and
it should proceed by uniform rules and
those rules should apply everybody and
this is what the Wilson talking so as to
marry or Wed the interest of the
individual with the state so we won't be
so fractious and divided anymore that
was their dream see and I'll tell you
what I think stands directly against
that its nature medicine says we need
laws because we're not angels but we
need limits on the laws because the
people who govern are also not angels if
it did please God to govern us directly
you know maybe in some nobler way than
he governs a dog because dogs always act
like dogs all right at least ours do and
cats always act like cats and I'll just
tell you I think that's too bad but but
people have discretion over things right
and because they do but because they're
fallen and you can understand that in
the crystal sense which is a profound
sense or you can understand you for
political purposes these these things
are parallel you can say that we are
fallen because we are necessitous and
because we face our own deaths and feel
our own pains and enjoy our own
pleasures and so if you're going to have
a being like that you're going to have
the
of granting and controlling the granting
of power and so at the bottom forget
what the argument is between the
Democrats and Republicans they make lots
of arguments there's an argument between
the founding of the United States of
America and the thing we have today and
I think I've accurately stated its terms